all right so uh welcome back everyone i
hope you had a nice break thank you all
very much for
the very fun questions and discussions i
really enjoyed answering to some of them
and uh it it shows to me that uh i've
hopefully managed to motivate
several of you that
indeed focusing on representation
learning on graphs is a potentially
useful and fun thing to do
so now that we're hopefully on the same
page in that regard and we understand at
least on a high level how to build
neural networks that respect the
permutation symmetry constraints of
graphs and sets
let's dive a little bit deeper into our
main event for today graph neural
networks and its various exciting
connections to other architectures
so just as a quick recap we've finally
seen for the first time the geometric
deep learning blueprint in action on the
specific domains of sets and graphs
under the permutation symmetry governed
by the permutation group sigma n
and as a direct consequence of this
blueprint we derived a deep set
architecture and we showed it's a
universal architecture for modeling set
data and we've also shown that using
similar concepts we can extend the deep
set architecture into a graph neural
network architecture and i showed you
a broad categorization into three
different flavors of
aggregation that you can apply for graph
neural network modeling convolutional
attentional and message passing
so now we are ready to dedicate an
entire lecture to some important aspects
of graph neural network design
as a quick roadmap of how this is going
to proceed we will first study the
maximally potent gin and flavor the
message passing flavor in a bit more
depth just so you have a full picture of
the most generic data flow that we can
have over a particular graph structure
and then we will challenge some of the
initial claims that were potentially
made so we will first talk about this
idea of whether or not the gnn
should rely on a good graph structure
and also some ideas on how to apply
graphical networks without a graph
that's known a priori
and
then
we will investigate how powerful
graphical networks are from an
algorithmic standpoint and illustrate
some key ways in which we can make them
stronger one point i would like to make
right now at the beginning
is that
we will not be covering any coarsening
layers for graphs if you remember the
gdl blueprint we've talked about all the
components in that blueprint
except for coarsening
and the reason why
we are not going to cover that even
though lots of very cool research exists
on that topic is that basically until
now there hasn't really been a
state-of-the-art graph neural network
architecture that relied on these kinds
of local pooling methods so the main
reason for not covering them is simply
that
they haven't uh reached that level of of
real world global use yet although that
doesn't mean that there won't be
exciting research in the future that
will make it possible but i just chose
to cut them from this lecture to
dedicate as much time as possible on
some of the more interesting
state-of-the-art approaches that are
taking place right now
so just as a quick recap the picture you
saw towards the end of the previous
lecture three different ways to
aggregate information in a graph neural
network convolutional attentional
message passing starting from the
convolutional where we fix the
interaction coefficients up front and
pre-compute them based on the adjacency
structure towards the attentional
mechanisms where we can actually compute
an interaction coefficient
based on the features of a node and its
neighbor and finally the full-on message
passing blueprint where we can compute
full-on message vectors based on the
sender and the receiver
and as i said we will start our
discussion for this lecture by focusing
on the message passing gnn specifically
and if you remember what we do in
message passing genons is we compute
arbitrary message vectors to be sent
across the edges of this graph
and the way we compute them is by using
this message function psi
which now looks at both the features of
the sender and the features of the
receiver when computing the vector to be
sent across and this idea has been
instantiated in models such as
interaction networks message passing
neural networks and graph neural nets
from
deepmind and as mentioned you can think
of it as the most generic genon layer
where your edges no longer are a way to
aggregate or average neighbors but more
a recipe for the passing of data
this means they could have scalability
or learnability issues but they
also are the ideal choice when you want
to model things like computational
chemistry uh reasoning or physics
simulation problems
so
one thing that's very important to kind
of bring back to the story now is that i
said when we started to analyze graphs
that i will discard edge features or
edge scalers or anything we will just
think about
whether or not the node was connected to
another node and that's all to make the
maps a little bit simpler well not if
we've worked out the maths and we want
to talk about the most expressive gnn we
should really to hammer that point home
we should bring back the idea
that uh
graphs can have rich information at all
granularities not just on the node level
and now we will actually assume that we
have some features on all of the
principal components so we have node
features as before so xu will be
features of node u and in the context of
computational chemistry those might be
for individual atoms what's the type of
the atom what's its charge how many
hydrogens are attached to it and so on
we might now also have edge features
parameterized by pairs of nodes and
these features could encode the in the
context of chemistry things like what
kind of a chemical bond is it like is it
a single double triple bond is it in a
chemical ring and these kinds of things
lastly you might also sometimes find
useful to attach feature to the entire
graph so have a flat feature vector xg
for the entire graph and in the context
of chemistry this might encode things
like molecular weight or molecular
fingerprints and things like that
so
then you can use a very generic graph
neural network model to then define
latent representations on the level of
both nodes edges and graphs and i should
mention and keep this in mind it will
come in handy later in this lecture
that it is in principle possible to
extend this framework even further to
represent
things like hyperedges which would have
triplets of nodes and stuff like that
but uh one very important point is that
such inputs can usually be represented
uh using the language that i just
described you so i don't think we
actually need to instantiate a x uvw to
talk about the hyper edge we can
probably use the edge feature concepts
to talk about hyperedges
so now under this assumption of having
node edge and graph data and
we want to compute node edge and graph
latents so from x to h
we are going to define a general way to
build spatial graph neural networks
which generalizes all of the flavors we
talked about
and specifically i chose to use the
graph network model from deepmind as the
basis because it truly operates over
generic attributed graphs and the other
two models like interaction networks and
message passing neural networks are
obtainable from the graph network by
restricting its equations slightly
and the general data flow here is you
first use the graph and the two relevant
nodes to compute edge features
then using those edge features
as messages you can update the node
features by aggregating those edge
features
and finally once you've updated both the
edge and the node features you can do a
permutation and variant aggregator to
combine all their representations and
use those to update the graph features
and of course because it just helps
learning a whole lot especially for
these over parameterized models skip
connections are utilized quite
extensively in this architecture so
let's go through what it's doing
as i said the first step we're going to
do is update our edge features so
compute the latence huv
and what are all the relevant features
for updating the edge well you have
obviously the two node features incident
that edge so xu and xv
and then you also have some features of
the edge xuv that are relevant and you
have features from the graph which might
also be relevant for updating that edges
feature
so this first step
should be fairly straightforward use the
relevant two nodes the edge features and
the graph features to update the edge
features
once you have all the edge features you
can interpret them as an edge message
and based on their aggregation update
the features in the nodes so now we can
update the features of a node u
by looking at that node's features so xu
by looking at the aggregation of all of
the edges that are sending into that
node
and finally the features of the graph so
this is now a second function that will
update our node representations
using these edge features and for now
you might see that this is really just
another instance of the message passing
rule we talked about before we just have
that extra context from the graph
and finally once both the edges and the
nodes have been updated we can use the
aggregation of all the nodes and all the
edges as permutation and variant
representations and using them we can
update the graph features
by the way a very similar formulation
can be recovered without explicit graph
features by just inventing a new node we
call it a master node and connecting it
to every single node in the graph
so let's try to visualize what's going
on
imagine i have here some feature vectors
in nodes u and v and the edge connecting
them and i also have some features in my
graph what will a graph network model do
as we said first we will update the edge
so the features of edge uv get updated
based on the features of the two nodes
incident to it its own features and the
features of the graph
once we've computed all edge features
sending to a particular node we can
update that node's features by using the
node's previous features
the aggregation of all the edges
and the graph level features
and finally once we have the computed
node features and edge features we can
aggregate all of them together to update
the graph features
now if you were to color code these
edges by whether they represent the
equivariant or invariant layer to
permutations you'll see that basically
all of the ideas from the geometric deep
learning blueprint
feature quite extensively in graph
networks with equivariant and invariant
layers applied appropriately whenever
you need to reduce something and it is a
very fun exercise then to try to specify
the functions sci phi and rho the three
key functions of the graph network to
recover some standard graph neural
networks like the gcn the graph
attention network or the message passing
neural network assuming i give you also
some imaging graph features i think it's
a fun exercise to try to complete
outside of this lecture
and
before we dive into some of the more
advanced topics of today's lecture so
this was just to show you a very high
level concrete implementation of one
particular expressive graph neural
network
but now we're going to move on to some
more advanced topics and before we do
that i want to give you just one last
thing to ponder
when we've introduced deep sets i was
i've showed to you that we've been able
to actually rigorously prove that any
set function that works in terms of
satisfying permutation and variance i
must be able to express it using deep
sets and now the question arises
can we make a similar generality claim
about the graph neural network we just
built can we represent any permutation
equivalent function over graphs
using one of the three flavors that i
showed you
and later today from several angles
we're going to ponder this question
quite carefully and it will be a useful
topic for the practical exercise that
you will have shortly as well
and yeah basically i just want you to
keep this question in the back of your
mind and have a thought of
are we sufficiently powerful by talking
about one hop neighborhood aggregation
to express anything that we might want
to do over a graph that satisfies
permutation equivalence
but before we dive back into this
we are going to move on to a very
important topic latent graph inference
which tackles one very innocent but very
important assumption we've been making
that we have a ground truth graph and
that graph is given to us
however it turns out this claim is not
so innocent
and analyzing it in more detail will
lead us into latent graph inference
which is a key emerging area for graph
representation learning and in my
opinion also an area of high interest to
just performing basic science
and further if we study this area
further it will allow us to draw very
cool connections between some
state-of-the-art models in graph neural
networks and to give you a bit of a
spoiler alert almost everything that we
will analyze will turn out to be a
special case of a graph neural network
so
specifically
one thing that's very important to note
is that even when i give you an
absolutely correct input graph which by
the way in the real world is quite rare
usually the graphs we obtain are a
result of some kind of human design
heuristic on which edges to draw and
what to put in those edges but even when
you give me a completely correct graph
that does not mean it is the optimal way
to pass messages for the task at hand i
always like to give a different example
for this for example if you want to
predict uh some movements
of humans based on their
skeleton pose
technically if you use the skeleton as
the edges in the graph that is a correct
graph of the human skeleton but imagine
you need to do some kind of synchronized
motion with your hands
actually this means you should have a
direct link between the two hands
to model their interactions very closely
right but actually in the human skeleton
there's no direct connection between two
hands you have to go through the entire
torso to reach the other hand which
means your information must travel
an unreasonably long
unreasonably long distance and this is
as you might imagine a sub-optimal way
to convey information
so even if you have an absolutely
correct graph which very rarely happens
rewiring it to be specialized for the
task you're solving might be a very good
idea and we can even take this concept
to the extreme right like what do you do
when there is not even any graph to
begin with but we assume that one might
exist okay so
imagine for example in the case of
physics you have a bunch of particles
these particles are interacting with one
another but you don't actually
explicitly know the forces at play
between them right you just see the
motion of those particles right and you
need to kind of figure out what is going
on in between so in this generic setting
we assume that we're given a node
feature matrix x but no adjacency matrix
attached to it and once again we'll
ignore edge and graph features just to
keep things a bit more simple it doesn't
change our findings
and uh what can we do
well
we have actually seen one solution for
this uh problem already right and that
is the deep sets model in which we
basically just assume that there are no
edges to begin with right so if no edges
are given to us we just go
pessimistically and we assume our graph
is completely disconnected so we let our
adjacency matrix equal to the identity
matrix or equivalently the neighborhood
for every single node u is just the node
u itself
and as a result no matter what you
choose to aggregate over the neighbors
you'll just end up with the features of
that node itself so you can easily
convince yourself that any graph neural
network flavor you run over such a graph
will reduce the deep sets so now we have
our first interesting result
deep sets are basically a special case
of a graph neural network where the
adjacency matrix is the identity or we
assume no edges
okay so
we said that one option is to assume
that there are no edges whatsoever
between our nodes
does anyone have any idea on
what could be another possible
option
maybe we can try to think that there are
edges connected to everything
yes exactly so all connected to all as
someone also wrote in the in the
comments
and that's exactly the case so the
converse approach is you can take the
lazy approach where you just assume
everything is connected to everything
which in matrix terms means that you set
your adjacency matrix to be equal to
uh
all ones multiplied by the transpose of
all ones or equivalently the
neighborhood of every node is all the
nodes
okay
and
since
we are assuming no additional
information about these edges right
remember we are supposed to be inferring
them as we go along
then a convolutional graph neural
network would have no other choice but
to take simple averaging into account
and it's possible to show in this case
that convolutional graphical networks
are equivalent to deep sets in the case
of smoothly connected graphs and it's a
pretty fun exercise to prove this and i
highly encourage you to try to prove
that
when you assume full connectivity and
you use a convolutional dnn with
averaging
that actually you will get the model
which is equivalent to deep sets so what
this means is with convgns we are not
going anywhere further than deep sets so
we need to try a more expressive flavor
of gnns well as we know the next step up
is attentional gnns
so here i put in front of you the
equation of an attentional graph neural
network
where the only difference i'm making is
now i'm making the neighborhood of node
u be equal to all of the nodes so the
aggregation operation goes over all of
the vertices and now i compute this
attention coefficient between all pairs
and i use that to elevate
maybe you know a quick question does
anybody in the audience see this model
and think oh this is something very
familiar
are there any natural language people in
the audience
yes exactly
good job iman this here
should feel a lot like a transformer
so some of you as i said here have
probably recognized the famous language
processing model in the equation i just
showed you but uh
i don't want to start this discussion by
saying transformers and like link them
like this i actually want us to
rediscover the concept of the
transformer
without ever talking about transformers
by just focusing on the geometric
blueprint i've showed you so far okay
so to do this i'm going to send you into
a natural language processing realm
and the reason why this is a good thing
to do is generally there's a
long-standing alignment between natural
language processing and graph
representation learning in fact many of
the early methods for representing
graphs the node embedding methods very
much one-to-one correspondence to
traditional word embedding methods uh in
in natural language processing
even their optimization objectives are
near equal once you take into account
these equivalences
and recently self-supervised graph
representation learning methods borrow a
lot of concepts from popular nlp methods
like birth
but what's very important is that we can
take this correspondence in the other
direction as well
so
in a natural language context you are
typically interested in modeling
sentences of words
and
then doing something over those
sentences like translating them or
predicting the sentiment is it positive
or negative or something like that
and uh
generally you can observe that words in
a sentence interact right so you have
subjects and objects you have adjectives
that act on the words they act on and so
on so there are some very interesting
interactions between the individual
words in a sentence that modulate the
meaning of that sentence or how it
should be translated okay
and
uh generally we know that these
interactions are not trivial and more
fundamentally not sequential so it's not
like one word interacts only with two
words that are immediately next to it
these interactions can stretch across
even multiple paragraphs
so this means that you probably
shouldn't
focus on using just a recurrent neural
network like an lstm because what is an
lstm assuming it's basically assuming a
grid graph that every word is connected
to its two immediate neighboring words
and as a result it's using a graph that
is in principle correct but suboptimal
for the task at hand
we might actually want to use a more
general graph structure between the
words to be able to model the meaning of
those words but then the big question
arises what should be this graph of
words okay
like there are many different ways to
define graphs of words and the problem
is not even you know professional human
annotators tend to agree what the best
graph to use is and often the optimal
graph might even depend on what you're
doing right the best graph for
predicting the sentiment of some
sentence and the best graph for
translating a sentence to a language
might be completely different okay so
what do we do when we have this problem
of we know there's a complicated graph
in there but we don't know what it is
well as we just said a very common
assumption is to use a complete graph
and then let the neural network the
graph neural network infer the relations
by itself by passing messages along this
graph
and
basically the most popular approach
indeed in that case is to take a fully
connected graph and then use the
attentional flavor of a gnn which then
yields one of the most recognizable deep
learning models of today which was
developed by ashish vaswani and others
that
at europe's and that is exactly the
transformer so here i put the equation
of the attentional fully connected gnn
in the corner and the famous figure from
the transformer paper so you can relate
some of these concepts but the general
idea that we want to make now that we've
arrived at the same conclusion is that
you know i've reached the definition of
a transformer without ever using the
word transformer i've just used concepts
of graphical networks fully connected
graphs and attentional flavors therefore
we can say that transformers are a
special case of graph neural networks
under these two assumptions
and you might wonder because graph
neural networks are permutation
invariant
what is it that makes transformers
specialized to language well
specifically this sequential structural
information is fed through the
positional embeddings of the transformer
which tell you roughly for every word
where is it in a sentence but
the model is not obliged to use that
information in any way it's there just
to hint to the model there exists a
structure it is not a rigorous
equivalence constraint so from the
perspective of equivariance constraints
transformers are in the same boat as
graph neural networks
and specifically you might imagine the
attention mechanism because it gives you
a scalar for every single pair of nodes
as giving you a soft adjacency matrix
and therefore letting the graph neural
network choose its own edges this
connection of transformers and gnns is
very beautiful and
there's a lot more detail i would want
to go through that i cannot do in the
context of this one lecture so i highly
invite you to read this uh fantastic
blog post by chaitanya joshi that was
published in the gradient which is
literally called transformers or graph
neural networks you'll find a lot more
fun insight in that paper
and another thing that's quite useful to
ponder for us is why did the attentional
flavor of the gnn work so well here like
why not message passing for example
well there's a few important concepts to
ponder the first one is that words don't
really have any meaning in themselves
right words only get meaning when you
put them in context with other words
right and as a result all of the inputs
to a
language model are typically just one
hot features that tell you which word
this is in the vocabulary so they're a
very rudimentary identifier feature and
they're unlikely to give you complex
messages right this will no longer be
the case when nodes become something
more tricky like full concepts but as
long as they are words then basically
taking weighted combinations of words
might be the best that we can do to
model semantics so attentional
coefficients then allow us to also
interpret these learned connections and
how a word's representation is built in
context with other words
but another thing which is obviously
most practical in terms of scaling these
models transformers are now used for
huge language models with billions of
parameters like gpt3 and as we discussed
before attentional mechanisms just have
a more favorable storage complexity than
full-on message passing gnns
especially when you use something like a
dot product attention like a transformer
does because you never actually have to
compute edge messages which is a much
more costly uh thing to do from a
storage perspective and also because
they operate over a dense graph you can
express computations of transformers
using pure matrix operations and as a
result you'll get something that aligns
really well with the computation of gpus
and tpus which are the workhorse behind
most of the deep learning progress
happening today
so
taking all this into account you can
basically say that transformers are
graph neural networks that have
successfully won the hardware lottery
they just happen to be the flavor of
graph neural networks that is easiest to
scale on the hardware of today and gives
you sufficient modeling power beyond the
convolutional gnn which is maybe a bit
too rigid if you want to read more on
the hardware lottery sarah hooker has
this amazing paper published last year
in communications of the acm which as i
said is highly recommended if you want
to know more about
why sometimes we don't choose the best
model for a particular task because the
hardware we have doesn't align with that
particular mod
but that being said the idea of taking a
fully connected graph is not something
that's restricted to transformers and it
works very well with the message passing
flavor as well if it's in the right kind
of setting so whenever you have
interactions between your nodes in more
complex ways than words so physics
interactions relational reasoning and so
on then the message passing flavor might
actually be a better choice because it
lets you compute a more complex message
along every single edge and actually in
such cases transformers often do not end
up sufficiently expressive it's actually
one of the rare scenarios where
transformers are not state of the art so
for some examples in physics modeling
interaction networks were one of the
pioneering works that treat every
interacting body as a node in a fully
connected graph and for visual reasoning
the relational network model
is capable of having superhuman
performance on relational question
answering by basically treating every
pixel representation of a cnn as a node
in a graph
and here you can see some interesting
visualizations both from interaction
networks here you can see some rollouts
of the interaction network model for
predicting and body dynamics both for
gravitational interactions on the left
bouncing balls in the middle with
elastic collisions and the strings on
the right and you can see uh for all of
the scenarios you see the trajectory
that's ground truth and the trajectory
predicted by the interaction network and
you can see that actually
they are very closely very closely
aligned
but
one thing that i would like to note last
year for the for this course this was
actually a full-on component
nowadays i am cutting it out a little
bit to put more discussion on the
transformer connection
but one thing that i would like you to
keep in mind is that the real truth of
latent graph inference so figuring out
the underlying graph and then using it
for a g n
is somewhere in between the two
approaches we've we've seen right we
have the option of taking no edges at
all we have the option of take every
pair to be connected right but there is
something in between right because the
full graph the fully connected graph can
be quite hard to scale because you have
quadratic space and large neighborhoods
but empty graph then ignores a huge
wealth of information so ideally what we
want is to infer a rigid adjacency
matrix a which is sparse and then use
that matrix as edges for a g and n this
is what we commonly term latent graph
inference and it's a very tricky area
that deserves a niche of its own because
choosing edges is a fundamentally
discrete decision and it's very hard to
optimize that by back propagation
and there's five recently proposed
prominent approaches that i would highly
recommend you check out if you're
interested in this area i highly
recommend it i think it's going to be
one of the most important areas going
forward especially if we want to use
these models for basic science because
these adjacency links can then be
interpreted as the ground truth
connections between our objects right
and there are many ways including the
neural relational inference or nri model
which uses a variational approach the
dynamic graph cnn or dg cnn which
basically uses a non-parametric model
with no learning at all but still quite
powerful
it's successor to differentiable graph
module which uses reinforcement learning
to decide which links to put
and then our own pointer graph network
which uses direct supervision from a
template data structure to figure out
how to place the edges
most recently at last year's nerfs the
slaps architecture from baharia fotami
and others which uses a self-supervised
approach to
significantly enrich these latent edges
they get discovered all of these papers
are very much worth the read if you have
some time
but in the interest of maximizing the
time and the utility we spent today i'm
actually going to pivot this discussion
now to talk to you a little bit about
how powerful are graph neural networks
so
i hope the wealth of practical examples
i showed you at the beginning can tell
you that graph neural networks are
indeed a powerful tool for processing
real-world graph data if you include all
of the transformer advancements as gnn
advancements that list only explodes
exponentially
but
they won't solve any tasks specified on
a graph accurately right there's still a
polynomial time procedure so they
shouldn't be able to help you with say
problems that we know are mp complete
and
the canonical example that we use to
measure the expressive power of gnns to
see like what they can and cannot do
is by looking at the decision of graph
isomorphism
so the main question here is
can the graph neural network distinguish
between two graphs that are not
isomorphic so can it attach two
different hg representations to them
okay
we know because of permutation
equivariance and invariants that
a gn is guaranteed to put the same
representation on two isomorphic graphs
so here we're really dealing with the
converse case
and the reason why this is important is
because the if the graph neural network
is unable to put different
representations on two different graphs
then any task that classifies them
differently is hopeless right so it's a
kind of a fundamental measure of how
discriminative you are can you
discriminate between any pair of your
examples so we're going to assess power
of gnns by which pairs of graphs they're
able to distinguish
and
to make this truly formal we will look
at a popular graph isomorphism test
which is known as the wise phyllo layman
test or the 1wl which is a simple but
powerful way of distinguishing
graphs that passes random hashes of sums
along the edges and just iterates until
those hashes stay stationary and if the
hashes are same in histogram terms then
the algorithm says these two graphs are
possibly isomorphic it was a procedure
invented by two soviet mathematicians
boris weisfeiler and andre lemon
and basically
it's a very simple procedure that works
remarkably well for most real world
graph structures
so to illustrate what this model is
doing we're going to run the wise filer
test on this particular graph here that
i showed you on some instances before as
well how will we do this we're going to
represent these hashes as colors which
makes sense because inherently they have
countable semantics and
once we have these colors we will track
all possible neighborhoods that arise in
terms of different colors and just put
different colors to different cases and
we stop when there's no new colors to
introduce okay so we start with this
initial graph where all the nodes are
colored blue and we have this particular
structure
after one step of the weisphela layman
algorithm we have two cases right we
have a blue node with two blue neighbors
which we decide to color green
and we have a blue node with three blue
neighbors which we choose to color
yellow okay
now i have a question for the audience
what do you think will be the situation
in the next step of the algorithm
i'm guessing maybe
looking at the color
coloring
with respect to the color of their
networks
yeah so how many different colors do you
expect we're going to have in the third
step
maybe three
if we don't consider the numbers like
how many ukraine and you know
then we just consider green green and
green yellow and yellow yellow
you are absolutely correct and the
people on the chat are also absolutely
correct in the next step we will have to
invent one new color
because now we have three cases right we
have green with one yellow and one green
neighbor those will get one color gray
for example
we have a yellow with two green that
will get a new color like red and we
have green with two yellow which will
get a new color purple for example and i
hope you can all convince yourselves
that at this point there's nothing else
to do in the next step we will get
exactly the same histogram of colors so
the algorithm just stops and outputs a
histogram of colors one two two okay and
now you can see how if we run the same
algorithm on exactly the same graph just
presented in a slightly different way we
will end up with exactly the same
histogram so in this case the algorithm
correctly recognizes these two graphs
as um as isomorphic
and uh
this idea of passing random hashes along
edges
makes it a very clear connection to
convolutional gns and that's been
spotted very early even the gcn paper of
kipf and welling has spotted that what
their model is doing is maybe a more
sophisticated variant of the weiss filer
algorithm and it also explains why
sometimes if you don't even train your
gnn like if you just have randomized
weights which corresponds to a random
hash you can get pretty strong
representations however even though this
test as i said is very powerful for many
graphs in the real world
it still fails on some painfully simple
cases this is one case it cannot tell
apart a sixth cycle
from two triangles okay so to the naked
eye these two graphs are very different
but from the point of view of the wise
filer test every single node is
structurally exactly the same in those
two graphs so it has no way of telling
them apart so there are some painfully
simple things like usually relating to
counting simple substructures that these
wise filer tests cannot do properly
and it might then surprise you to find
out that if your features are discrete
you can never build a graph neural
network that is more powerful than the
wise filer test
and
this might seem a particularly damning
prospect but actually when you analyze
it further you might find that even you
need to be very careful with how you
designed the gnn to even match the power
of the weisfelder test you know you
cannot exceed it but it's also not very
easy to match it either
and it turns out that the condition to
get this maximal power is for your
aggregation function to be injective and
in this particular case
the aggregation function that works well
is taking the sum
okay
so why does this work imagine you have
this neighborhood of discrete features
like four blue nodes and two red nodes
if you take the sum of all of their
features you will correctly capture that
there are two reds and four blues right
if you take the average you're already
throwing away information you're only
representing like
the relative ratio of blue to red which
is two to one and that already drops the
information how many blues and how many
reds there are and if you take max
that's even worse because it just
reduces your multi set of neighbors to
the set of the constituent blue and red
okay
and the proof that shows that
you need the sum aggregation and using
that you get the same expressivity as
the weisfelder test is actually very
similar to the proof used to show that
deep sets are universal
the main difference is that deep sets
dealt with sets
when we aggregate over graph
neighborhoods we now have to deal with
multi-sets because
because we can have multiple neighbors
with exactly the same feature
so
using this
the authors of the graph isomorphism
network paper or jin
have been able to show
that
you can compute a you can have a simple
gnn which uses the sum aggregation which
is maximally expressive so here you can
see that you have some component that
depends on the center node and it's
weighed by this factor of epsilon which
is learnable
and you have also a summation over all
the neighborhood features and
this layer the gen model is provably the
most powerful gnn over discrete features
however
like just because i told you you can
never hope to build a gnn that's
stronger than the weiss filer test well
what does that really mean that just
means that the graph neural network is
fundamentally incapable of computing
certain things
so what can we do then we can build more
stronger gnns by giving them that
information that they cannot compute
okay
so there is a huge area which i like to
call augmented message passing which
tries to build more powerful gnns
usually by looking at the cases where
the wise father test fails and then
finding ways to give the graph neural
network the context that it needs to
solve that problem and here i've given
you this example of the six cycle versus
two triangles again so that you can so
that you can properly
properly keep it in the back of your
mind while we study this
so for example
the reason why we cannot tell apart
two triangles from a six cycle is
because if you look at the receptive
field of a graph neural network applied
to these constant feature graphs you can
see that every node in these two graphs
is exactly the same receptive field all
the nodes locally look exactly the same
okay
so do you have some idea of a very
simple thing we could do to the input in
this graph to fix this problem
any ideas
is there anything simple i can do to the
node's features to
not make them look the same
the idea to add another node joseph is
very interesting and could be quite
powerful but let's say for now
let's say for now that i
am not allowing you to add new nodes it
is a correct answer but
i'm looking for something even simpler
okay it seems like we don't have any
takers so let me show you what the
answer is
you can basically just put a random
number inside every single one of those
notes right
and now suddenly not only do these
neighborhoods look different you can
also
see yourself a certain number of hops
away which tells you hey you've closed
the cycle of a certain size right
so basically the the key point here
is that
if you already augment the graph neural
network with something as simple as a
random number
you can already tell apart some
substructures that previously you were
not able to tell apart specifically you
can tell apart a six cycle from two
triangles in this way okay and
essentially
uh this is
a very powerful idea even though it's
remarkably simple and ryoma sato with
his collaborators was able to take this
idea and publish it in a top tier
conference in the year of 2021 this is
just to show you how
uh how young this whole field is and how
impactful it could be where you can
basically write an entire paper on the
theoretical significance of putting a
random number in every single node and
get that paper published at a top menu
okay
and there's this is just one instance in
a whole family of approaches that tries
to put features in the nodes that
compute something that the graph net
otherwise wouldn't be able to compute so
besides putting random features you
could also put node identifiers
positional identifiers and pgns and even
if you know which substructures are
important you can literally count them
and put the features of those counts as
your positional features this is exactly
what jorgos buritsas did in his paper it
came out in 2020
and
this general idea of finding a case
where a graph neural network cannot deal
with the one wise filer test limitations
and fixing it by changing the features
or something like this gives you a
method that belongs to augmented message
passing so there's many of them there's
really a lot of them but they can be
generally categorized into three groups
you can either modify the features of
the nodes as we just discussed you can
modify the message passing rules so
change the message function so that it's
more mindful of the structure of the
graph the directional graph neural
network or dgn is a very good example of
this
and the last suggestion which
aligns really well with what joseph
suggested is you could modify the graph
itself to give you clues about the
structure and this gives you some models
like one two three gnns and it further
subdivides into various categories like
rewiring the graph aggregating over sub
graphs or message passing over
substructures
now one thing that's very important
because i'm sure many of you will
doubtlessly look into the literature for
these kinds of approaches
and if you look up the papers that
improve on the weiss filer layman
limitation there's a high chance you'll
come across some terms like higher order
gnns or beyond message passing
i've had a lot of debate with my
teaching assistants at cambridge and
external experts on these terms and i've
actually convinced myself that it's
likely impossible but certainly not easy
to truly devise a graphical network that
you cannot express using message passing
and actually many of these stronger gnns
that you build are going to be most
efficiently implementable using message
passing so what's the trick how do you
make it work well don't do message
passing over the initial graph modify it
by introducing for example new nodes to
represent substructures as joseph
mentioned
and
as a result you know you change the
graph but the primitive that you use is
still message passing over one hop
neighbors so therefore i conclude that
talking about the term beyond message
passing can be imprecise at best and
potentially harmful because it might get
you to think oh i need to implement this
without using any message passing
whatsoever when in reality message
passing just over a different graph
might be the best way to do it
and this whole story started when i was
giving my course on graph neural
networks at cambridge i made a slide
that i also presented to you today on
how graph networks can represent
hypergraphs and these kinds of things
and this caused a very lively debate
with my uh
with my teaching assistants with which
eventually spiraled into a bit of a
long-standing argument the the ta who
originally reported this issue notedly
said that he did open a pandora's box
and
all of that discussion eventually led to
me writing this position paper on
message passing all the way up where i
make a very clear argument for why you
should be able to represent everything
using message passing neural networks
and this work was recognized in the
iclear gtrl workshop where i presented
it as a spotlight a few months ago and i
had a chance to have many intense
discussions with people including some
folks from this course like michael
bronstein on to what extent is this
claim true i'll just say that to this
point i haven't seen any clear evidence
that we cannot express things in message
passing it's just that sometimes
expressing things in message passing
might not be the most insightful way of
looking at it
and the other term
higher order gnns
relates to
usually trying to build graphical
networks that align with more
generalized versions of the wise filer
test remember when we first introduced
it i mentioned it's sometimes called the
1wl that means that we're keeping
representations on nodes which is like
one tuple of nodes but it's only a
special case of a more general class of
weiss filer tests the kwl which track
representations for k nodes at once so
pairs of nodes triplets of nodes and so
on but
not all graph neural networks are best
talked about with respect to the wise
filer test which as we said at the
beginning means you're deciding
isomorphism over discrete featured
graphs very often graphs you will
encounter in nature might have
continuous features attached to them so
we set out to study what happens when
the features are continuous rather than
discrete so we break the first
assumption of the gin paper and we
actually find that in this case the
proof for the gin papers injectivity of
the some aggregation falls apart and i
can easily give you examples of
neighborhoods that cannot be told apart
by the sum aggregation
or even the min aggregation or the max
aggregation it actually turns out that
for some of them like the third one from
the left here the only aggregator out of
the four we're considering here that
will tell them apart is the standard
deviation taking the sum the average the
minimum the maximum doesn't tell these
two neighborhoods apart so this raised a
very interesting question right
since there doesn't seem to be a single
aggregator that always works
which one is the best
so this prompted us to write a paper on
principle neighborhood aggregation the
pna paper and we actually prove
mathematically that there isn't one okay
so if you have multisets of n neighbors
where the set of features is the real
numbers
are in general going to need at least n
aggregators so one aggregator per
neighbor to tell them apart to tell the
isomorph the non-isomorphic ones apart
in general and if you're interested in
the math behind this i think that the
proof of this statement is really cool
it relies on the borsig ulam theorem
which three blue one brown wrote a very
fun tutorial about that you can find on
youtube so highly recommend it
and you might be asking yourself now
you know okay so i told you that
to distinguish uh general neighborhoods
with continuous features you need at
least n aggregators so do we have any
idea on what those n aggregators are
well in the same paper we actually
proved that the moments of the
neighborhoods work so you take the
expected value of the nth power of the
difference between the mean and then
take the nth square root of that to get
the nth moment so
these functions gradually generate first
the mean then the standard deviation the
skew the kurtosis and so on and so forth
and it actually also covers max and min
because when you take the maximal and
the minimal element taken together they
give you an estimate of the infinity
moment right the biggest discrepancy in
your data set
now the important thing to note is that
these guys are not always the optimal
choice of aggregator there are other
bases that might also satisfy the
condition of being enough and also
there's a problem with them when you
take them to n bigger than two so when
you move from standard deviation into
skew and kurtosis territory you have to
take the nth power followed by the nth
square root and this is quite
numerically unstable in practice so what
did we do as a result in our principle
neighborhood aggregation paper we
propose a combination of these
aggregators which is shown to be
empirically powerful so we take the
aggregators that we know are stable like
the mean standard deviation and then the
max and min which are stable at m
infinity
and we combine those four aggregators
with three different scaling functions
like identity multiplying by the degree
which allows you to recover sum as
degree times mean
and also logarithm of the degree so
these three combinations multiplied by
four aggregators give you 12 different
aggregators and then you just use this
combination as your aggregation function
in your favorite graph neural network so
you compute all the 12 aggregators and
then you concatenate the results
and stitch it into your gnn and you're
all set it tends to at worst match the
performance of individual choices of
aggregators and usually outperforms them
especially as you need to extrapolate
more
so
that was actually the last concept i
wanted to cover for you today
so it's good to have a recap of
everything we covered we took a deep
dive into graph neural networks
specifically we looked at the exact data
flow of the graph network architecture
from deepmind over generic attributed
graphs once we covered that we unpacked
the seemingly innocent assumption that
the edges given to us are perfect and
analyzing the scenario where we don't
even have any edges we recovered
transformers and deep sets as two
special cases of gnn flavors
over either an empty or a complete graph
and finally we studied in depth the
limits of graphical network expressive
power which i hope also addresses one of
the questions we had on the first
lecture we studied them through the lens
of graph isomorphism testing we found
that gnns are fundamentally limited by
the weiss father test
we found a way to break this limit by
giving gnns data they shouldn't normally
be able to compute giving us augmented
message passing methods
and finally we discussed briefly why
just studying effects over discrete
features is not sufficient enough in all
cases and our analysis into the
continuous feature space led us to
discover the pna combination of 12
aggregators
i hope you found this lecture
interesting especially because now that
you're armed with the knowledge of the
gdl blueprint on the case of sets and
graphs you're ready to move beyond to
just simple from permutation symmetry to
more complicated geometric constraints
and this will lead us to talk about
geometric deep learning over grids and
groups where it starts to get quite
exciting from a geometric standpoint
i hope you enjoyed this was my last
slide and i believe i should have about
five to ten minutes for any questions so
yeah hope you liked it
yes thank you
so there is a question
hello
yes yes could you read out this
so there's a question how to perform
backprop true notes in genning
how to perform backdrop through the
nodes of genome okay that's a good
question so i think it will be easiest
to visualize it if i
show you again the data flow of
of the graph network model
so this picture here
so imagine that you know you're
predicting something on the level of
nodes edges and graphs so you have some
label for both
hv huv and hg
the back prop basically just goes in the
opposite direction right so these psi
phi and rho are simple multi-layer
perceptrons and any gradient you've
computed on the vectors for hg hv and
huv can then back propagate through
those functions into their inputs right
and therefore optimizing the weights of
those parameters so i hope this i hope
this answers the question generally we
just look at these data flow arrows and
we look at them backwards to back
propagates through the functions that we
care about
okay
someone is typing i think maybe
wait for a few seconds
yes so there's another question what is
the main
institution of adding epsilon
uh-huh so i think this epsilon like
please correct me if i if i
misunderstanding but
i think the epsilon here refers to this
gin formula here
where the epsilon is added to the self
connection
so
basically
you'll have you'd have to read through
the paper to truly understand why that
epsilon needs to be there but basically
the idea here is that in their analysis
they want something that will take the
sum of all the neighbors and then treat
the central node in a way that's
guaranteed that you can unpack it from
the rest of the neighbors okay
and uh if you assume that the inputs and
neighbors have discrete features
one typical way to uh
to make sure that uh this central node
is given a special treatment
is by multiplying it with some
irrational number so in the basic
mathematical analysis of this layer
epsilon is seen as just some irrational
number okay now of course you cannot
actually you know
represent an irrational number inside a
computer
so what they do in practice is they make
epsilon be a learnable parameter
and the hope is that then back
propagation will discover an interesting
enough rational number to tell apart the
central node from all the other ones so
that's the that's the main intuition
basically
to be able to use sum for all the nodes
including the central node without
having to use the skip connection
concatenation